relative infectiousness of
individuals who never have symptoms and
here we have these
three references again lee at all which
is reference nine
they say they looked at 303 patients and
found approximately 100 percent as
infectious
wow okay okay that milk then 75 seems
like a decent estimate okay
cha at all 2020 which was their
reference 15.
they uh this paper says they looked at
1701
uh secondary contacts and found an
infection rate of asymptomatic compared
to symptomatic individuals of 40 to 140
percent
wow okay that's asymptomatic individuals
are
more infectious than symptomatic
individuals according to this paper
better go look at the paper
curiouser and curious curiouser and
curiouser yes and then the third
reference that this
johansson at all paper looks at is
mcavoy at all
which is actually a a modeling paper
itself
actually it's a review paper that tries
to do some modeling and they found
a mere 40 to 70 percent and and from
those three numbers
these authors concluded 75 about right
so well let's see if any of those
numbers hold
right let's let's see what we have in
um there we go
um nope hold on sec thank you um in
li at all uh what they did was they
looked at 303 actual patients in a
health center in south korea
uh cool it's it's empirical
this paper finds compellingly that viral
load
and asymptomatic patients is similar to
that in symptomatic patients
okay and they're not the on this is not
the only paper actually to have to have
found that that viral load is similar in
asymptomatic patients
and symptomatic patients but guess what
viral load
is not the same thing as infectiousness
or transmissibility
it's just not it's not the same thing
and
the authors of this paper leodoll which
are cited by johansson at all to support
their ridiculous claim that a hundred
percent
they so this leodoll paper johansson is
claiming
claims a hundred percent as infectious
for asymptomatic versus symptomatic
patients
say quote although the high viral load
we observed in asymptomatic patients
raises a distinct possibility of a risk
for transmission our study was not
designed to determine this
and under the limitations of their own
work they say quote
we did not determine the role that
molecular viral shedding played in
transmission from asymmetric patients
so take away one of those three
references that johansson had all fined
um doesn't provide any evidence of
transmissibility much less a hundred
percent
okay that's one we are going to get
through these other two pretty quickly
reference 15
cha at all uh it's an empirical paper
tracking cases in brunei we're following
a super spreader event in malaysia so
brunei is a small country
there was a a big event like 16 000
people a religious event in malaysia
some number of people came home to
brunei and and a small country
uh with a lot of track and trace
possible and so they were actually able
to to look
at um what happened so another empirical
paper
that's pretty well done actually i was i
was um pretty impressed with this
it's a complicated analysis with a lot
of variables and
just a reminder that uh johansen at all
find that this paper
found 40 to 140 percent
of cases uh for 420 percent
of asymptomatic case no asymptomatic
cases are
40 to 140 as infectious as symptomatic
cases
that's what johansen reports about this
paper well what does this paper actually
find
it finds that in the household setting
which is the only settings where they
could find anything statistically
significant
symptomatic case patients had 2.7 times
the risk of transmitting cyrus cov2
as combined asymptomatic and
pre-symptomatic patients
so that's a conservative member so you
know again sorry for all the numbers but
almost three times as much
infectiousness in symptomatic patients
versus the combined asymptomatic and
pre-symptomatic and never symptomatic
patients
and when you look further into their
paper you find that of course the
pre-symptomatic patients
are more infectious than the never
symptomatic patients
and what you don't find is any evidence
for 40 to 140 percent
there's nothing in this paper at all
that suggests
that asymptomatic patients are more
infectious than symptomatic patients so
where are they getting these numbers
quickly just the last paper is a review
paper
uh and they they're they're doing it
carefully
it's review through only through april
8th 2020 so it's you know early in the
pandemic
which separates out never symptomatic
from pre-symptomatic cases
and it's a careful review and what they
do is they say
we can't tell there's not enough out
there yet the literature is not rich
enough
there's not enough empirical work we
simply can't tell and they specifically
point to variable definitions of what
infectiousness means
and they say okay so very tentatively
given that
we think that maybe asymptomatics have
about a 0.4 to 0.7 rate of
infectiousness to that of symptomatics
which is exactly the number that uh that
johansson
cite here and if you could just show my
screen one more time zach
once again we have these three papers
that the new johansson is basing their
the neutral handsome papers basing their
numbers on
liadol which was from south korea which
actually
has um in my finding no evidence at all
for transfer transmissibility and
johansson says approximately 100 percent
cha at all which was the case from
brunei which
uh as far as i can tell shows um a third
or less
asymptomatic patients are a third or
less infectious
as symptomatic patients and they say 40
to 140 percent on the basis which i i
cannot even begin to figure out
and mcavoy at all uh which is a highly
tender number says 40 to 70
well that number they actually got right
you can see that here they actually got
that number
they pulled it directly from the paper
and it's you know it's right there
so my conclusion from all of this
is that johansson had all this new paper
which i expect to start seeing reflected
in um you know in the cdc's guidelines
and various health officials um
recommended behavioral changes um
is that their their baseline assumption
of 75
infectiousness of asymptomatic relative
to symptomatic cases is
completely unfounded completely
unfounded and
it's possible but we literally have
no evidence for that in the papers that
they cite
given that nothing in the conclusions of
this paper should be taken seriously
no policy should be based on it and we
should
seriously question any of the work that
these guys are doing going forward
because what the hell were they thinking
so can you go back to the title of the
uh the piece the
the main one yeah yeah sars cov2
transmission from people without covid19
symptoms so i think
a i'm wondering whether our longtime
viewers are having a bit of deja vu
because if you allow
yourself to squint at this just right it
is
very much like the situation and
unfortunately i didn't realize until we
were on the air
what the parallel was so i don't have
the name of the paper but
the paper that declared idw part of a
mechanism of online echo chambering
has the very same nature in which they
build a model
that creates a shocking impression of a
particular hazard
and when you go back and you scrutinize
what it is that
allowed them to build the model it is in
fact perfectly circular they built into
the model
something that allowed them to pull that
conclusion out and in fact in that case
we had the author of
the article on which their assumptions
were based saying hey you've misused my
work
so it is exactly the same form which
then raises i think a very interesting
question which is
why is why are we facing an epidemic
of this style of science who is certain
well who is served by this who like
i think either who are they working for
or why are they this confused or why are
they
this bad at actually understanding how
it is that you build a model that can
produce
a result that isn't exactly what you fed
into that model
um i believe the problem is that we are
up against evolution
um what's happening here is very helpful
is it
it's it'll it ought to properly frighten
us and uh get us to wake up because
you know first of all it's mundane but
realize that positions
uh in academia for example are
um scarce and therefore competition to
get them is ferocious and the way one
gets compete
to wins that competition is to publish a
lot of stuff
publish stuff that gets cited by others
etc so in some sense there's a niche
if you can say things that people will
pair you're going to do well
and in fact we see this if you look at
you know citation rates and how
they affect getting hired it's
spectacular
even when you're being cited because
you're being mocked
right in other words the fact that your
paper is cited a lot by people saying
this isn't true
doesn't necessarily count against you so
what i'm getting at here
is i don't know why this is showing up
in
jama right that's shocking and dangerous
as you point out because policy is
almost certain to be founded on this but
what i suspect
is privately as we've seen in many
different places
in the sarsko v2 kovid story
there is a behind-the-scenes consensus
about what
wise public policy is yes and then the
facts are rearranged around it to make
it look like
it is also in your interest as an
individual and so
the idea that um we have a large amount
of transmission from people who never
show symptoms of course is justifying of
a lot of the most draconian measures
to prevent the spread of uh covet 19.
and so
in any case what that means is that
people are looking for evidence that we
need to do that those who have concluded
for whatever reason
responsible or not public spirited or
not
those who want to impose those
restrictions are looking for things that
justified and this paper is liable to be
uh confirming of their worldview correct
or incorrect
and so in any case i guess what i'm
saying is you've got authors
searching for that which the audience
demands and this is
you know as uh politics is the opposite
of patriotism
uh giving the the audience what it wants
is the opposite of science
science is supposed to tell you what's
true irrespective of what you want to
hear
this isn't science it's circular right
the point is it looks like science it's
dressed up
as science and it is presented in a
sciency place and that is going to be
enough
to drive policy